a debate is contentious a debate is
about winning a conversation is about
truth-seeking together when i saw the
debate devolve into personal attacks i
felt like that was a loss for me as a
viewer hey guys i want to talk about
this new netflix documentary called the
game changers it's all the buzz in town
my patients are asking about it you're
asking about it so i decided that i'm
going to make a video on the topic but
instead of overloading you with a ton of
information i decided to source three of
the most popular questions that you have
and three of the most popular questions
that my patients have and i'm going to
answer them within this video full
disclosure not only did i watch the
entire documentary but i also watched
both episodes of the joe rogan podcast
the first where he had chris cresser on
essentially debunking the documentary
and then the second one where he brought
in james wilkes from the documentary to
have a debate with chris kresser about
those qualms that's in total about seven
hours of footage i watched it all i
wanted to make sure i came prepared to
answer all of your questions i want to
start off this video by giving you my
baseline thoughts on the subject going
into watching the documentary so that
you can be aware of my cognitive biases
now we all have a bias in fact when i
watched a debate between james and chris
on rogan's podcast i saw their cognitive
biases showing and i think if you're
more aware of my cognitive biases and
where i'm starting my starting point is
you'll be able to make a better judgment
as to whether or not the information i'm
presenting you is accurate or where it's
coming from and why i think what i do
think as a board certified family
medicine doctor who's done a lot of
research on the subject the
recommendation i give most often to my
patients is a whole foods primarily
plant-focused diet doesn't mean vegan it
means getting the majority of your
calories from non-animal sources but it
also means it's okay to eat fish meats
albeit red meat in moderation and we're
moving to the greatest extent possible
processed meats now in this diet you'll
have a lot of fruits vegetables healthy
fats like avocado nuts olive oil things
like that it's actually quite close to
the mediterranean diet we have to
remember though that nutrition advice
should be really given on an individual
level so i don't recommend that to all
my patients that's sort of my general
advice and then we make
little changes based on that person's
body their health their conditions and
what they hope to achieve so while i've
never explicitly recommended the vegan
diet to somebody if a patient comes in
and wants to i make sure they do it to
the best of their abilities
supplementing blood testing and making
sure they're planning to get the right
macronutrients let's get into my
thoughts before we jump into the
questions i'm really happy this
documentary was made it's debunking a
lot of the myths we've been propagating
for such a long period of time like we
need to eat a certain amount of meat in
order to put on muscle a lot of these
have been proven to be untrue and i'm
happy that this documentary is putting
it out there in fact i'm happy that
we're discussing nutrition we're
actually learning about what constitutes
good research why we're so misled with
the certain headlines that we see in
media i love that we're discussing this
i mean this video rogan's video the
documentary itself all the response
videos this is all healthy debate that
we need to do more and more often in
nutrition so that we can raise the bar
on the type of research we're doing we
can actually make a meaningful impact on
the future generations with nutrition
research that being said the science of
the documentary is pretty solid uh all
the facts are well stated there's
sources for everything that appear on
screen i love that in fact in a lot of
my videos i try and put you know links
for further reading from major
organizations like who cdc or if i'm
referencing a specific study i put that
study in there as well the one thing
that i will say is i do feel it was made
from an activist scientist standpoint
the reason i have to make that a point
is
they didn't present any
counter-arguments and when you're making
a documentary i think it's in the
documentary's best interest if the
documentary's interest is truth-seeking
to put all perspectives in there at
least the most common ones so that we
can as viewers decide for ourselves
what's real what's not now the experts
that they had in the film are credible
experts they're some of the leading
experts in the world but when you only
have them speaking about it and no one
else from the other side of this
conversation you're leaving a void in
there and it feels like it's been done
intentionally from an activist
standpoint now i don't want to put blame
on anybody or assume why that's being
done i just think that it would have
been a more complete picture had we
heard from the other side of the
conversation about perhaps how much meat
is healthy is no meat healthy and sort
of get a little bit more
details on that now james wilkes who's
the star and co-producer of the film
explicitly stated that his goal with the
film wasn't to make everyone go vegan it
was to reduce the amount of animal
products that they're taking i love that
goal i think we should all be thinking
about that especially for the
environment's sake but what it feels
like in watching this film and speaking
to many people about it my patients
included the vibe that everyone gets
from watching it is that eating any
amount of animal product is incredibly
unhealthy and we're going to be getting
into that as we move forward in this
video but i feel that if your goal was
to send one message but in reality or
from a practical standpoint you're
sending a different message i think
something needs to be adjusted when
you're comparing animal food companies
to tobacco companies and we're talking
about dangerous words like inflammation
cancer and
referencing that only in terms of animal
products you're essentially scaring
people off in totality from it at least
in their minds so we need to be really
careful from not only are we presenting
all the information factually but also
how is it being
understood by the audience let's start
off with the youtube questions the first
one was the most upvoted and it was is
it true that all protein comes from
plants and that animals are just a
vehicle for that
i think when we're making these types of
reductionist statements we can really
get lost as to the practical value of
them let's use a metaphor
all people were once lower forms of
organisms because of evolution so we
were once bacteria doesn't mean we're
technically bacteria not really and the
fact that a cow can eat a ton of grass
and make it into a lot of protein it
does not mean that we can eat that same
grass and turn into a lot of protein
there's differences between animals and
humans so don't know what to make of
that statement i hope that answers your
question question number two will going
vegan give me more energy first of all
it depends what are you switching from
and what are you switching to if you're
switching from a very unhealthy let's
say the american standard diet where
you're eating a ton of burgers and
pepperoni pizzas and things like that
and then you switch to a healthy vegan
diet you're gonna feel like you have a
lot of energy but now on the other hand
let's say you were eating already a
mediterranean diet and now you switch to
a vegan diet but one that's unhealthy
you're eating a ton of refined carbs
processed foods that are still vegan
you're not going to see a dramatic
increase in energy in fact your energy
levels may fall i don't think it's a
magic pill like in the documentary some
of the athletes said oh before i was
performing so horribly and now all of a
sudden i have more energy if they were
eating healthy before and switched to a
vegan diet
i don't know how much we can say that it
was the vegan diet that caused it
directly perhaps in individuals we can
say that but not as a general rule we
haven't seen the evidence for that
question number three how did you feel
about the experiments that they showed
in the film that was probably one of my
biggest issues with the film i
understand what they're going for
they're trying to debunk a lot of these
myths surrounding
performance and masculinity and how you
can be vegan and still do well in all
these aspects of your life and that's
true but i wish they didn't resort to a
lot of these examples that weren't
scientifically meaningful like what does
it mean to see triglycerides floating in
your blood what does it mean that these
three gentlemen didn't have the proper
erections at night when they ate
something else it's not a controlled
experiment there's so many variables at
play and the sample size is tiny like i
understand why they had to do these
visual demonstrations because it works
really well in the documentary in fact
when producers call me to do morning
shows or daytime talk shows they always
ask me to bring in demonstrations just
like that or little experiments but
unless i can say they're scientifically
valid or whatever it is i'm proving
makes sense i don't feel that i should
do it because i don't want to mislead
the audience by any means all right
let's move on to the patient questions
these are the ones that are the primary
questions that seemingly everyone had
the meat of the discussion if you will
question number one i'm looking to put
on muscle and i want to go vegan can i
still put on size absolutely yes and i
think the strength of this documentary
was debunking that old myth that you
couldn't be vegan and put on muscle you
absolutely can you have to plan
accordingly supplement accordingly
making sure that you meet all of your
amino acid demands but outside of that
make sure you have a good workout
routine i'm actually going to be showing
you my workout routine in a video coming
soon are there any health concerns with
going vegan and can we all go vegan the
vegan diet is one that's appropriate for
all life stages they said in the
documentary and i couldn't agree more
with that it's not necessarily the first
diet that i reach for when i recommend
it to my patients but it absolutely can
work it's just important that it's
appropriately and well planned and i
know in the joe rogan debate james made
a point in saying all diets need to be
well planned this is true but the vegan
diet does require more effort in that
you really need to plan your protein
your supplementation and you generally
don't have to do that if you're eating
an omnivorous diet if you do happen to
go vegan but do it in an unhealthy or an
unplanned way you could actually do
serious harm to your body you can
develop b12 deficiency which will lead
to anemia you can develop other vitamin
or mineral deficiencies most notably
vitamin d and calcium and also if you're
trying to put on muscle if you're not
planning your protein sources correctly
you could also get in trouble in that
way but for most people that shouldn't
be much of a problem and the mack daddy
of them all the final question the
question that so many people have asked
me the question i've even pondered after
watching the documentary myself are meat
or animal products as unhealthy as they
say and do i need to get rid of all of
them to stay healthy i rarely am so
blunt in answering questions like this
because there's usually a lot of nuance
but the answer is no i think the
documentary went one step too far
in fear-mongering uh people to eliminate
meat out of their diets completely in
fact james on the joe rogan podcast said
that frankly that he believes that no
amount of meat is safe or healthy i
don't think that's the case i don't
think evidence has proven that to be the
case i think we just don't know enough i
think the research that we have is
really flawed we have industry funded
research underfunded research research
that's done with questionnaires my
answer would be if you're eating a
healthy whole foods plant focused diet
and you eat some meat i think that's a
very healthy diet i think eliminating
meat completely is a personal choice i
don't think it's one that you normally
have to make for your health albeit
nutrition is an individual thing and if
your doctor recommends that
there might be a different conversation
for you but there's one thing that i
love about this documentary that i want
all of us to take away from it we should
all reduce the amount of animal products
we're eating we're overeating calories
as is specifically animal products
processed animal products we need to get
this garbage out of our diet it's one of
the main reasons obesity is overflowing
in the united states in addition to
refined carbs so yes we should lower our
reliance on animal products we should be
eating more fruits and vegetables and in
fact me doing whole30 right now one of
the takeaways that i've gotten from this
is that i should be eating more fruits
and vegetables and that i have been
relying on getting all my protein
specifically from animal sources so this
documentary did bring awareness to that
and i'm really proud of it for doing so
just saying that we should remove all
animal products completely as james said
not a huge fan of that i don't think
there's evidence to back that up i think
when you compare a vegan diet to an
american standard diet it does an
amazing job of overturning illness even
but when you compare a vegan diet to
someone who's otherwise healthy and
omnivorous
i've never really seen evidence to show
that vegan diet is superior and the
interesting part about it is
most if not all major organizations
agree with that james made a really big
deal in the podcast saying how chris
cresser's views on nutrition were not
matching scientific consensus well james
views aren't matching scientific
consensus i haven't seen any guidance
from the who or cdc to say that we
should not be eating animal products
altogether i've seen that they recommend
we should increase our vegetable and
fruit intake decrease our processed food
refined carbs our red meats or processed
meats but to say to remove all animal
products
not scientific consensus i want to leave
you with some thoughts that i had about
the joe rogan podcast where james wilkes
and chris kresser debated about the
documentary i know joe rogan framed this
as a debate where chris debunked the
documentary james saw
that episode was very upset about it and
he wanted them to sort of battle it out
or duke it out with their information i
don't necessarily want to see a debate
from these two gentlemen i want to see a
conversation a debate is contentious a
debate is about winning a conversation
is about truth seeking together when i
saw the debate devolve into personal
attacks i felt like that was a loss for
me as a viewer i think that these guys
are so smart they've done countless
hours of research between them and they
can bring a lot to the conversation and
i think both of these gentlemen agreed
more than they disagreed and it didn't
come off that way by the way they were
talking with one another it almost
seemed like they disagreed on everything
it's not true and i think their only
real point of contention is should you
go a hundred percent animal product free
or go mostly animal product free and i
think that's such a my new difference
that our research with the low quality
that it is right now
i can't really tell which one of them is
right so i still say to my patients that
they should eat a predominantly
plant-based diet with some animal
products in there removing processed
foods as much as they can i put together
a playlist for you of all my nutrition
videos including going vegan for 30 days
so click here and if you have any
residual questions leave them down below
in the comment section because i want to
answer them